the
world will remember this
day the Trinity tests and the revelation
of the first atomic explosion to the
world was one of the most important
moments in the 20th century the Trinity
test and the development and the race
and the fact that it was all attempting
to save kind of humanity from fascism
what was really interesting was going
back and trying to understand what these
guys were thinking and the terrible
decision that were placed in front of
them I knew this was going to be one of
the most important things to technically
figure out when Chris makes a film he
wants to do as much as possible
practically and it's absolutely all
about creating a world that the audience
can identify with in the start everybody
is just scared shitless everybody resets
sequence nobody knows how to approach it
because with Chris it's always the same
we have to figure out ways to do these
kind of things in camera and every time
when you get sort of overwhelmed by it
you take a step back and you make it a
little bit simpler you know and slowly
you know a scene like this sort of grows
and and comes to life we try to get
permission to shoot at the actual
Trinity test site at White Sands Proving
Grounds unfortunately as Proving Ground
is busy with bombing runs and you know
all these different things we weren't
able to physically fit in their schedule
I got with the scouts and I said okay
well this whole stretch looks the same
essentially it's the same mountain range
range and so we moved 60 M North so we
were in the exact placement just
literally 60 Mi up here at Trinity
there's so much you can dig into as far
as schematics and the way that the
telephone poles were laid out and the
wiring we just follow the research in
terms of dressing the interior bunker
the really cool thing is you could
physically go into the bunker and go up
to the window and there's your Tower and
you know we could cheat the distance in
the lens was pretty unreal who builds
102t replica of the Trinity Tower
there's so much historical stuff out
there you want to make sure it looks
right and you just do the research
building the gadget itself that was fun
we're able to kind of help tell a little
bit of that story of how it gets
assembled the core and the plutonium and
all the you know and how it all goes
together Chris likes everything kind of
for real you know like the winch and
everything set up for the bomb was
pretty legit the way it was talking on
Ruth set that's where I I really felt
this is what they would have seen this
is really what this looked like this is
where they detonated an atomic bomb are
we saying there's a chance that when we
push that button we destroy the world
chances are near zero near zero what do
you want from Theory alone zero would be
nice it's an extraordinary moment in
human history and I wanted to take the
audience into that room and be there for
that conversation and and be that when
that button is pushed you're dealing
with the biggest themes the biggest of
moral dilemmas and what's at stake you
know what's at stake is
insane one of the trickiest things was
to kind of plot oppenheimer's sort of
moral journey through all of this cuz
he's kind of dancing Between The
Raindrops this kind of moral puzzle that
he was confronted with it's happening
isn't it Killian's performance is so
Mercurial and so subtle that you kept
guessing as to what this guy's itions
really are cuz you see him become the
King of the Hill in Los Alamos and quite
like it it was a very conscious thing
for Oppenheimer he was very consciously
creating his own iconography it wasn't
an accident the Hat on the pipe that was
very thought through I think the
silhouette is one of the most important
signatures that you could create for a
character the silhouette is what takes
the audience through their journey of
the story that that's before them there
are no real color photos of Robert
Oppenheimer there is a colorized photo
on Life magazine and from that the most
important element was the blue shirt and
so we decided that Robert Oppenheimer
will always wear a blue shirt our
continuity was really aging some people
had four or five different looks I think
the challenge is to on IMAX create all
of the these known people and do the
Journey of their life on film but with
that kind of detail I think that's the
biggest challenge I ended up going to an
Opticians and got a pair of my glasses
magnified and then I do my checks with
those glasses which have ended up in a
funny way being called the IMAX glasses
didn't need a charge what I knew from
experience having done you know a
nuclear explosion via computer graphics
and Dark Knight Rises which worked very
well for that film and I was very
pleased with with everybody's work on
that film it showed me that with a real
life event like Trinity that's as well
documented that footage is very
accessible that computer Graphics would
never give you the sense of threat that
you see in the real life
footage you know right away you're not
doing the explosion that they did so you
got to figure out a way that you're
going to at least get something big
something we could repeat from different
angles and was going to kind of get it
right you're ready ready you 100% thank
you okay we are because you know people
definitely take a better look at his
movies and especially the accuracy on a
film like
this so on this show a lot of the um the
effects work is you know special effects
and visual effects very much bundled
together Andrew together with Scott
Fisher their whole sort of unit was one
big science
project this is a thing for simulating
the shock wave from the atomic bomb
there's a slider we cover this bed in um
thin dust and then release that and as
these little wires slide under the dust
it kicks up like a little shock
wave the two of them did a lot of R&D
they did a lot of experimentation they
came up with some very interesting
analog
methods a lot of different types of
explosions a lot of different frame
rates approaches to how to film it with
the camera a lot a lot of different
things going into that
sequence on top we have about 60 gallons
of gasoline with some high explosive and
we detonate that and then about 2/10 of
a second later we detonated some
aluminum powder for some bright flash
and then about almost a half a second
later we detonate the motar at the
bottom which is gasoline and Diesel and
black powder and that pushes up through
to kind of create our mushroom CL okay
we're hot here we go roll cameras
rolling rolling rolling spe hey go I
think for uh modern day effects this is
kind of bigger than normal back in the
day a lot of uh this was common place on
on a lot of movies but I think now they
uh well not quite this
big it's also all about buildup Jennifer
she's a brilliant editor with the help
of like classic film language and
editing you know they built up this
Crescendo that is really really really
really impressive in so many different
ways for me it's like the lead up to
that was the most interesting and like
you know these guys you've been through
it with them learning their faces and
you know who looks like what and who
looks scared and who looks super
confident so you're like rooting for
them and you want them to be safe
there's a point where the music takes a
big shift and that's when they're
getting ready to do the final test and
the whole musical tone just completely
changes going from things that sounds s
like music to things that doesn't sound
like music so I'm I'm using all these
different sound effects and making that
into a very stressful emotion using it
as using music more like sound design
you can feel it more in your body than
in your ears and it just feels very
uneasy it's an interesting kind of point
where you can almost like breathe out
but with a big
tension with the Trinity test I
approached it moment by moment I found
firsthand descriptions really intriguing
and really
inspiring it was really just all the
little details all the little bits of
Machinery they used old analog equipment
humming all this equipment is more or
less period accurate you know the
solenoid activates the Detonator but all
these sounds are just meant to kind of
keep us in the suspense of
waiting there are moments that that
demand
silence it's kind of counterintuitive
because in movies you expect to hear the
explosion when you see the explosion
when it does go Kaboom you have been
lulled into this sense of astonishment
that is all about playing contrast to
get the reaction out of the
audience our work here will ensure a
peace mankind has never seen until
somebody builds a bigger
one what we were able to do for the
Trinity test and get into the Finish
film to me is extraordinarily
beautiful but also very
frightening